jay mazzini just got an arrest warrant
issued by the
fbi he's been detained by the fbi
and we got new charges related to the
bitcoin scam
we covered a long time ago we've been
going after jay mazzini for three months
guys
over three months and boys he's done
the goose is cooked he's finished we're
doing the long intro today because
oh boy got a lot to talk about ladies
and gentlemen
welcome welcome one and all my name is
coffeezilla
and you're entering the 10 million
dollar studio boys home of the internet
detective
let's go to the let's go to the desk
okay
oh my gosh i'm sorry if i seem a little
excited today you'll have to forgive me
it's pretty unusual normally we talk
about people
and you know they just keep ripping
people off but in the case of jaymen z
i said since day one that this man's
different he's different
he's ripping people off so cynically
that i knew he was going down i
i knew it okay and we've been saying it
on this show now
for i think my first video on jay was in
in december like early december december
10th
and it has been a saga it's been like a
game of thrones
epic adventure multiple videos multiple
scams
literally we haven't even covered them
all at this point i mean have you guys
ever heard of habibi life that was
another one of his scams
there's lawsuits that he's involved in
that we haven't even talked about but
this man
was uh scamming so blatantly so
out in the open that today i'm gonna
walk you guys through it
all culminating in the fbi getting
involved again
we've talked about how he was arrested
that was for kidnapping charges
now the fbi have gotten involved for
different reasons
and uh their charges look eerily similar
to a certain somebody's video so we're
gonna talk about all of it guys i'm just
so happy
this is such a vindication to the
victims
who have stepped forward in all of this
you guys don't understand
i talk to victims all the time and you
know a common thing is like
is it worth it do i come forward yes
yes yes yes and it this is the best
example of why
he wants to go out like as cynically as
possible ripping off his
fan base i was right uh so i said it
there
over here when we were talking to the
bitcoin victim we also had a similar
point expressed are you willing to go to
court about that
oh i would uh i think this is bigger
than the court case
you're right about that ahmad you
definitely were my friend
you were right and then again another
one of his victims
said the exact same thing where do i see
this going
honestly i'm hoping to god i hope he i
hope he rocks in jail
everyone has said the same thing which
is that this guy
is headed for for jail i mean he is
doing things
that are so unconscionable and um
i had to call it out because i was like
dude this might take too long
we got to protect the victims and so
um that's exactly what we set out to do
and i'm happy to say
that a few days ago or about a week ago
jay mazzini was
arrested but not for the reasons we had
talked about for
kidnapping charges now at this point
he's just been scamming
for so long but again he wasn't charged
for that initially he was charged
for kidnapping okay he kidnapped a
person and we actually interviewed that
person
um here's a quick thing of his injuries
we're going to be talking to him
very shortly about exactly what happened
but all you need to know is that it all
culminated today in this
look at this court case the united
states of america against jay mazzity
first of all that's incredible
it's a complaint and arrest warrant um
done by the fbi again guys right here
fbi
have now gotten involved with jay
mazzini and actually
you can even see in his arrest page it
even says that this is the detainer
point
this previously was not filled out when
we first looked at the arrest
the federal bureau of investigation
hadn't been involved but this is
absolute proof
this was uh now is included in his first
arrest which is for
um again kidnapping the fbi has also
just taken over the case i mean it seems
like they've just like taken over this
whole thing
and it makes sense because of how bad
the situation is
so let's go over what he's now been
charged with by the fbi now that i give
you guys
all that context for what's been going
on
and um can i just say i mean look have
we taken a moment to just i mean
oh there we go uh congratulations
to you guys you guys made all of this
possible i mean
seriously with you guys raising a big um
you know raising hell about this
i really do believe that this may not
have happened without that
um and you can actually see in the
charges some familiar people
so check this out guys beginning in or
around january 2021
the defendant jabara igbar also known as
jay mazzini began using his social media
accounts to solicit followers
to sell him bitcoin we've talked about
all of this if you've watched my video
i'll leave a playlist of our jamazini
scam
series you can watch it yourself but
here's the important thing
one such individual works for a company
based outside the united states that
held bitcoin and was looking
to obtain u.s dollars individual two
contacted the defendant
also known as jay mazzini igbarra
promised that he would wire
195 000 in exchange
for 5.049 bitcoin now why does that
sound
familiar well let's go back in time a
little bit
and watch our first video on j mazzini's
bitcoin scam i sent him
5.0 btc
oh how familiar that's exactly the
number we talked about
in our video in addition it mentions the
fact that uh
jay mazzini sent the guy a copy of his
passport identification page
okay now remember what we said in our
video
he gave he provided with full kyc right
so he provides with
passport now i know you guys are
starting to get the picture here but um
i mean let's just go through the full
thing shall we please please
give me this one okay this is a very
special day
we've peaked okay honestly honest to god
we faked now the next person they
mention is somebody
who transferred approximately 750
thousand dollars
worth of bitcoin to jay mazzini
and jay apparently sent this guy a td
ameritrade bank account that was
uh supposedly holding 3 million dollars
in it now
again remember what was our second
victim that we talked to saying yeah
sure let's go ahead and i'll send you an
invoice
look at that 750 000
that sounds awfully familiar
oh my gosh dad
guys honestly um i'm just doing this
because i'm so
proud of the victims who came forward
and you know i'm just so proud of
each and every person who spoke out
against this man
and really you guys are the ones who
brought this man to justice listen
without the brave people who spoke out
against jay mazzini
there is no arrest there is no bringing
this man to justice
um so i want to take a second to thank
everybody who came on the show
was brave enough to put their face on
camera
and explain the fact that they got
scared that's a hard thing to do
um and if you've been scammed by jay
mazzini you can go
to the internet crime complaint center
it's called ic3.gov i think that's the
best place
to submit your um you know complaints at
this point
it's never too late to submit your
complaint whether it's about jay mazzini
you've been scammed by something else
this is just a great portal
to submit your complaints please it
really look
is this not evidence it really does make
a difference
let me give you guys the the final part
of this whole thing which i find to be
hilarious
which is that this guy was telling um
our
our victim that he had look at this
three million dollars
to transfer to individual number three
but in actuality this was a lie
and the balance in the account that he
was talking about was approximately
a hundred and sixty-two dollars jay
mazzini
claiming to having three million dollars
actually had a balance of 162 dollars
are you joking this man who scammed so
many people
he doesn't have any money he's broke you
guys have been following a broke
loser total loser who is now in jail
uh detained by the fbi arrest warrant by
the fbi
i mean this is just mind-blowing and
i lo i love it i mean you guys can
probably tell this is like
one of the greatest days of my life
oh man this is uh it's a blast and i
and again you'll just have to forgive me
for kind of making this whole thing
long-winded because
man i am enjoying every second of it
this is not gonna happen very
often but it's proof again that this
stuff
does matter oh man it's just
mind-blowing
so to everyone who submitted their
complaint to the fbi recently
um thank you thank you for helping
make the world a little bit better of a
place to everyone who's been scammed
don't be afraid to use your voice guys
scams are criminally
under-reported you guys need to report
it when you've been scammed
justice is slow but it will come
so uh with that being said i guess
that's all i really have to say
thank you for watching hope you enjoyed
this recap
and i will see you guys tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen